[Music]
[Applause]
bringing Chris Haynes been a busy guy
covering the NBA finals for Bleacher
Report and a TNT sideline reporter if I
didn't watch the game last night Chris
how would you describe it
you know what DP actually I was a little
bit surprised by the turnout of the fan
base of the Miami Heat they're not known
to be some of the most passionate on
time fans and so I was interested in
seeing how they were going to show up
and they actually showed up for the
first quarter they were there in their
seats
for tip so they were they were punctual
uh it didn't you know it it didn't help
wait that doesn't sound like the
Sacramento Kings of the early 2000s when
it comes to a home court advantage hey
how was the crowd last night you know
they were punctual
that I discovered and attended a Miami
Heat game they have an actual Club in
the arena like there's an actual Club
where I'm talking about VIP tables DJ
the whole club atmosphere they have it
in the arena and I remember I ventured
over there one time and it was a bunch
of NBA players who had their VI IP
booths had their crew their people with
them getting bottle service so I'm like
this is why fans don't show up really
for games this this is why they hear
clubbing it's it's unlike any other
place
that's part of the heat culture right
I keep I keep being told I'm force-fed
heat culture I don't know what the
culture was last night other than how
about somebody stop the Joker and Jamal
Murray we shouldn't be surprised with
what we're seeing I was a little more
surprised with Jamal Murray it felt like
he knew he knew he needed to step up a
little bit more and he certainly did but
I'm curious about Jimmy Butler we
haven't had that you know Jimmy buckets
here it hadn't been a great performance
so far in the NBA Finals there's
something going on that we don't know
about
I don't think so DP I think you know and
I'm getting credit to you about Jamal
Murray and feeling like he had to step
up you know going into that game three
that was the talk in the locker room
when I was talking to guys they were
telling me Jamal Murray is like kind of
salivating off the opportunity to go out
there and play well not just play well
because the NBA Finals but because Jimmy
Butler has switched on to him now and so
game two everybody felt like maybe Jimmy
was going to neutralize Jamal and that
simply wasn't the case he was still able
to get his shot off cleanly and with
rhythm but now you talk about Jimmy
Butler yeah he hasn't had those big
breakout games that we've seen him have
in previous rounds I I don't know if
it's defensively what the nuggets are
doing they're switching everything you
know Jimmy is getting the switches that
he wants you know Aaron Gordon will
start off on him then he'll get that
screen to get Jamal Murray on him and
then he's getting the shots and you know
a lot of teams talk about the Denver
Nuggets like they don't have Rim
protection and so you would think that
it will be a little bit more easier to
get to the basket but that just hasn't
been the case I mean Denver Nuggets are
a really good defense of the sound team
and that's why they're comfortable
switching from one uh one to four uh
Jimmy just hasn't been able to get off I
haven't heard any intel as far as if
he's you know dealing with anything but
he's getting his shots that he's getting
the shots off they're just not falling
with the consistency that we've seen in
the previous rounds I know I'm getting
ahead of myself but I shouldn't do this
but if Joker wins the title
let's say he's Finals MVP now all of a
sudden we're going to start with the
conversation about him compared to other
great centers so it he goes into a new
category he's going to go into a
category maybe with Akeem and David
Robinson and Patrick Ewing where you
know he's not Shaq but but you know two
MVPs winning a championship and he's
having one of the greatest finals
postseason performances in history do
you think it'll be fair if if they win
that all of a sudden now we start a
different conversation with him
not for sure I definitely think he's
he's worthy of that I mean two MVPs
already I mean the guy is Unstoppable
there's nobody that can stop him you
know he he doesn't get rattled you're
not going to speed him up because I
don't think he can be scared
so but he's just Unstoppable I mean and
just the awkward shots that he takes and
when he takes it you know guys feel like
yeah I forced him into a bad shot but no
like his shots are just ugly he's
comfortable taking that that's one thing
Anthony Davis told me in in last round
you know a lot of shots he would shoot
with the clock expire and he would just
get it off in back of his head and they
feel like that's a good shot no I mean
feel like that's a bad shot well it's a
good shot for him and so no I I
definitely think he's worthy to be in
that category of some of the big uh the
best big man we've seen in this league
and you know footwork you know I don't
think he gets enough credit for the
footwork his footwork is probably on par
with Hakeem
had the best footwork
um as a big man that we've ever seen
Joker is right there and then just what
he can just get his shot off without
using much athleticism and you know he's
one of the most talented guys we've seen
this league so no doubt I think he's
deservingly so should be in that
category if if he is to win a
championship Chris Haynes TNT sideline
reporter Bleacher Report NBA Insider
yesterday he had a report on Chris
Paul's future
now has he been released or is he
potentially going to be released because
I wasn't quite sure exactly what what
the headline was yeah so Chris Paul is
represent representation were contacted
yesterday and I received word that
um they were informed that the sons
intend to wave him before his salary is
guaranteed now the sons want to uh put
out that basically there are still
options there's still other things that
they're considering uh a trade is a
possibility if they can trade him before
that June 28th deadline but Chris Paul
and his representation were under the
impression
um after that phone call that he was
being waived which would make him one of
the top free agents this summer and uh
you know that's something he he's
looking forward to I can tell you he's
looking forward to seeing what's next in
store for him I was told he planned has
to play for several more years believes
he can still do this at a high level and
I think the the stats will still dictate
that and uh you know he just wants to um
get this situation resolved to get it
finalized so we can try to figure out
the next steps all right
I know going back to Los Angeles more
likely that the Clippers would welcome
him or the Lakers would welcome him if
you were choosing between those two if
you're choosing between those two
obviously it's still pretty early right
now uh we haven't got to that stage yet
but just if I'm just looking at the
rosters I think the Clippers are going
to really consider resigning Russell
Westbrook so it probably wouldn't make
much sense over there
um the Lakers
you know they they acquired D'Angelo
Russell in the um mid-season that didn't
work out really well so it's unknown
what they're going to do with him but I
think if you're if you're minimizing it
just to those two teams it probably
makes more sense with the Lakers
I know that uh you've reported on Damien
Lillard and what could happen they have
the number three pick in the draft and
you know this is Portland at a
Crossroads are you going to go young and
invest in the younger players you got
two weeks to decide this is Dame Lillard
traded before NBA drafting
you know I speak with Dane pretty
frequently
um
about basketball about life in general
but you know we we talk about
he would agree that this is kind of like
a Crossroads situation right here the
Portland Trailblazers have the number
three pick Damian Lillard wants to win
he wants to win now he wants to compete
for a title
I don't think he believes that
um taking that pic and keeping it is
going to do them any service in the now
so I think you know what the Portland
Trail Blazers decide to do with that
pick will dictate well let's say they
take scoot Henderson
if you're Dame Lillard
do you want to stay
if I'm if I'm Dame Lillard based off of
what he said if they take if they keep
that pick whether a scoop or anybody
else if they keep picking
pick a serious conversation will be had
about potentially pardon ways
all right
who do you trade him to
I think if you Illustrated it'll be in
the Eastern Conference I mean Dame went
on went on record
I
oh he said the way he told me yesterday
he was like they put him on a spot where
they said they eliminated other teams he
said so he said that clip was not being
played they actually eliminated or you
can't say this team you can't say this
team but between these three or 14 which
teams make sense he said so that's how
he answered it and he said that part was
actually cool he doesn't fold Under
Pressure not not on the court now all of
a sudden they're saying all right you
got to choose between these teams um
okay he could say I'm with the Blazers
I'm with the Blazers he could have but I
think I think that is like I could
see the Nets I I could because he could
be the star there although I mean I
don't know how that front office is the
ownership it's dysfunctional but by
comparison to the Knicks you know we're
always talking about the Knicks being
just functional I know Miami Heat he you
know he's friends with bam out of Bio
but I where let's say I'll make you GM
where are you sending him to
if you have to
if I have to I would think if it gets to
that point they would consult with Dane
because you know Dane's been there 10
years been a model citizen represented
that City in that organization with
class all throughout I think they will
try to get him where he wants to go in
the East that is I do not see an
envision
and uh I do not Envision a possibility
that he he would be traded to a Western
Conference Team what if we did this
though Chris from the Boston Celtics
and I signed no no he's not he's not
doing Boston he doesn't want any part of
Boston
okay all right okay so you can
confidently report that that Dame would
not want to go to Boston is that what
you're saying
I think that's pretty safe to say
yeah I was thinking Jalen Brown and
maybe something to Portland and then you
get team lemon but all right Nets Heat
anybody else that'll be on that list do
you think that he would want to go to
and will he dictate where he wants to go
or does Portland dictate if it comes to
that
I think he will have a large part I
think they respect him enough for what
he's done for the organization yeah
but next he I mean he mentioned it he
mentioned it on there Nets Miami and
possibly I don't think POS I don't know
Philly but they don't have what it takes
so I I'll leave it at the Nets in Miami
all right
uh how many games did this series go
you know what DP
I was hoping to see a really good series
um
Denver Nuggets are just too talented it
it takes an awful lot for the Miami Heat
to to stream to get a wins
they play with
talent wise they just they're just not
on par with the Nuggets but they play so
hard and they stay in it and we'll coach
I wouldn't be surprised if the Nuggets
closed it out in five whoa okay
gentlemen sweep there all right
no I wouldn't be surprised all right hey
great to talk to you as always
anytime DP thank you thank you that's uh
Chris Haynes uh TNT sideline reporter
Bleacher Report NBA Insider and you know
he's always on the phone
probably on the phone to Chris Paul this
morning
probably on the phone with Dame Lillard
later on today I like that